Women make 25% of
the films in Iran, compared to 4% in the US.By
2025, there will be more English speakers
in China than in the rest of the world put
together.
+
It takes 3,000 cows to supply the NFL with
enough leather for a year's supply of footballs.
A ball of glass will bounce higher than a
ball of rubber.
And a ball of solid steel will bounce higher
than one made entirely of glass.
Gram for gram, hamburgers cost more than new
cars.
The sentence, "The quick brown fox jumps over
the lazy dog."
uses every letter in the alphabet.
For this reason it is often used to showcase
typefaces.
A full moon is nine times brighter than a
half moon.
Dartboards are made out of horse hairs.
Beethoven would dip his head in cold water
before he composed to stimulate his mind.
A jiffy is an actual unit of time, it's 1/100th
of a second.
Russia didn't consider beer to be an alcoholic
beverage until 2011.
It was previously classified as a soft drink.
Months that begin on a Sunday will always
have a Friday the 13th.
The Titanic had a sister ship called the Olympic
and it provided 25 years of good service.
During its lifetime an oyster changes its
sex from male to female and back several times.
The average secretary's left hand does 56%
of the typing.
Despite China having a population of 1.4 billion.
There are only about 200 different surnames
in China.
Cotton candy was invented by a dentist.